hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Amnesia the bunker I
meant to play this earlier but I got
sick I'm better now which means that I'm
going to excuse me pardon me don't mind
me I'm better now which means that I'm
gonna play it now I don't know why I
feel like I need to perch on my stool to
be able to play this but I'm doing that
I know I didn't finish
um Amnesia rebirth and that was not
intentional what happened with that game
is that my save got soft locked so I was
in the game and I got to a point where I
died and then I was carrying an item at
the time that I died that I needed to
progress and when I got back into my
save I wasn't able to progress and there
was no like previous save version so I
couldn't even go back so I was stuck and
I would have had to play through the
whole game again and I just never got
around to it but this one I've been
looking very much forward to because it
seems to be more of a return to form in
terms of just the pure horror aspect of
it not that you know rebirth didn't have
its scary moments but it definitely
didn't feel like it wasn't all about it
it's not that they don't like the
stories that fictional games tries to
tell Soma is one of my like favorite
games of all time in terms of the horror
genre just because it lives in my brain
I think about it a lot craving an
intense nightmare be ready for
unforgiving Encounters in Extreme
Caution it now experience a chilling
atmosphere without the constant stress
of death now vital to adapt use caution
and strategize yeah let's go with that
because I have a funny feeling that uh
I'm gonna be bad at it we choose to be
expected I'm not terribly good at games
that's a lie I'm very good at games it
just depends on the games and how much
practice I have
which I don't have a lot of practice in
this one because it's been a very long
time since I've played an Amnesia game
any kind of custom story so I'm looking
forward to what this has in store for me
to survive this war you'll need two
things first a basic set of skills
second the good goddamn sense to do
whatever's necessary I can teach you the
first the second is up to you
thanks Romaine
oh God okay
well I can imagine that there's not much
else more horrifying than um War
put away the gun it's the guy I got the
gun do I have any bullets no I don't
have any bullets in the gun
damn
oh well that sounds ominously close
QE to lean right and left yeah that'll
be useful
um
so
oh
you okay buddy that doesn't look like
it was caused by
War oh it's a tank
okay
ah good old Amnesia door physics bullets
ah
load one
it's one bullet per box
how big is this bullet
I only get three bullets
I'm pretty sure they gave the soldiers
more bullets than this all right
whatever
I'm not gonna complain oh I'm
complaining
yeah do I huh
[Music]
oh don't worry about me I'm an old pro
at all this
I know exactly what I'm doing and
exactly when I'm doing it
door
I don't mean to mock the German language
um
but I don't speak German despite my last
name
oh no ah bull ET
great I have almost a full bullet gun
yippee
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God okay well uh oh my
God come here you oh ah this has gone
terribly wrong oh boy take that
and one of these
oh oh and one of those how about that oh
all right well I'm out
[Music]
there
okay buddy were you gonna do that that
Old Timer are you gonna wait until I ran
out of bullets
because uh kind of a dick move if you're
we're gonna just do you have no but what
were you shooting at me at with I have
to see how bad it is
God oh two fingers bad that's pretty bad
oh a little lock
okay I can't go this way
all right Henry
crafting oh interesting craft
craft requires for the crap
all right
hold down use use hold down ready like a
grenade
and then use it
I feel better that's not bad okay
so I'm Healed okay
let's have a funny feeling yeah let me
yeah okay all right okay I was pretty
sure about that
um
to the right is that a hint for me is
that supposed to be a hint for me who
the ride
that'd be a really clever way to put a
hand in the game if you have people
screaming in the back grenade
well I guess it is a war after all
uh anybody got a brick I mean
technically I have a grenade
is that what I'm supposed to do
there's no brick
I broke a door with a brick before
I don't know if I
don't think I have a brick uh I think I
got a Granada uh how far away do I need
to be
Retreat is that telling me to go back
because I oh I don't know
It's gotta be it's they wouldn't give it
to me otherwise right
right is that hockey four it would they
wouldn't give it to me otherwise right
okay here we go
oh yeah
Kai almost peaked out
I almost was like I don't know if it's
gonna go off I gotta look over there
then I would add my face blown off
uh
all right ever watch out German soldiers
I got a Grenade
oh
all right huh
all right can I carry that with me I
feel like that's very amnesia
no okay
do I have a bullet left
damn it
uh I have nothing okay is there no
bullet
did I miss a bullet somewhere if I got
bullet you got bullet bullet did I throw
this at him
so I gotta waste my other grenade oh man
I did not plan this right
I didn't do this right at all sorry
in the hole
I don't know about that one I don't know
about that one oh God
what oh my God oh my God
oh oh gas
oh oh gas Oh
Henry it's me oh that oh
ah okay
um
remember how I said I was bad at games
[Music]
oh
thank you Lampard
you're so kind
I would have done the same for you if I
found you
beat that roll my friend what
there you have it huh
Fate's a bastard I'm on patrol tonight
then
celery
did we make it alive or am I going to
get amnesia and then
um die
oh God why am I here
oh no they call this no man's I'm going
they call it no man's land for a reason
and I no okay all right well all right
then
this is good
this is very good
that is nice to be playing an Amnesia
game again
first game I ever did a let's play on
was Amnesia hello uh
uh oh there's someone there
Lambert already
yeah
then I'm going to get you out of here
I don't know about that one
I guess you saved me I could at least I
could do a save you
okay
[Applause]
no no no no no you're big and strong get
you back to safety just hold on to me
all right don't worry we're in a very
safe place right now and also I'm very
fast and strong did I didn't notice dead
bodies
I'm sure that's fine
oh yeah I'll go faster oh that's
probably not good oh
okay don't worry oh my God
Lambert
well you are now on your own learn adapt
experiment and survive
so Lambert survived yeah
he made it
I know I bet
okay
all right
ah
I think I have
um
how injured am I oh
that doesn't look good but at least
there's no blood
all right oh he's dork
oh it's still work
okay
uh-huh
he says electricity that's nice
okay
progress saved huh
good do I steal my gun nope
almost he picked up can be found under
the notes tab uh pressing the tab or the
icon is flashing okay
admitted to medical treatment following
events of 9th of July personal effects
held in the storage locker patient
remains in Weak coma state will respond
to stimuli but only for brief periods of
time when last roused he reported no
memory of recent events had trouble
recalling even his own name
most likely due to severity of initial
head trauma we'll continue to monitor if
status does not improve in a week's time
recommend transfer to sync and Etienne
for neurological tests signed Dr
josinski well that sounds fine I'm in
good care now
why do I want to throw everything I
don't know
that's a that's a habit I've always had
since I've played Amnesia but it's not
really a habit in other games not that
many games have like a full physics
system involved
yo this is so easy to Chuck things well
better uh turn out the lights before I
go everything seems fine here
good
great
good great
this is
this is good
oh no do I need to hide in your closet
oh the flashlight
okay
oh God
that's a terrible design that's a
terrible design
oh that's a terrible design
oh that's a horrible design
okay oh 9th of July 1700 hours
I mean a state of agony
it cripples my body captures my mind
beads my soul
this thing I've done these things
it is lunch in the mess hall currently
oh the thought of eating
repulses me is I apologize me uh let me
do the voice acting buddy so
you remember what you did am I clemo am
I on weak limo
oh
me ah I get it now
God capable of casting suitable Lipa
requires frequent minding great
because of course it does
because it couldn't be simple
why would it be simple
hello it is me oh is it fading
foreign
that didn't last at all
oh oh oh oh good
oh
good oh
oh why
this is the most
devious design for a flashlight one
could ever hope for
oh
oh no
I don't know thank you all right oh Dr
josinski the body of Sergeant Raynard
multiple lacerations chest cavity torn
to shreds every rib cracked skull
cracked open by repeated blunt force
trauma who could have done this to him
what it was nice what
foreign
all photos can be found under the photo
tab
oh
are you sure every Rib was broken are
you sure did you check no this looks
like some intact ones there
well that was oh God this thing I'm just
gonna walk and whine I don't care
I am not going to walk in mine
oh
if it's anything like Amnesia the first
one they're not gonna have the monster
right away they're gonna do a lot of
build up and then make me think that the
monster is right around the corner when
in actuality I'm completely safe
[Music]
well this is a tiny hole
hello ah looked
well this is great
I am
oh just so happy
[Applause]
maybe I shouldn't make noise
I know how to act
is that
a blood
that one's pretty
but why
it's the French who knows why they do
what they do I don't
ugh
my life is not supposed to cast any
light down there
probably not
hello
are you
are you sure about that
why
oh hello
I thought that was the last one
behind them
did they fascinating
you want to escape you need to blow it
back open there's dynamite in the
Arsenal ah and a handle to trigger it
somewhere in the excavation
so get them
okay bye
I think it's coming for me
for me take this finish me off
Soldier not that monster
um
who are you
thank you yes it is better in my hands I
agree
are you not in the pantry
why don't you have any bullets well I
guess you probably weren't able to all
right you know I'm gonna stop
questioning things is this a hot what
did I just pick up
I have meat now
okay
I'll take it
oh wow yeah okay
I don't know why I'm being such a baby
I've played this game before well I mean
I've played Amnesia games before
blade something is probably the same
hey yay
okay buddy uh close your eyes
oh this is the worst way to do anything
I gotta hold down to put that and then
my oh did I put both I thought didn't I
I put bullets in it already I already
loaded it up I don't even remember doing
that
aha
uh brother Soldier
are you well
oh okay
blocking that up oh yeah yeah let's
block that up
are we still at War
is war still occurring
is we doing War now
there's a terrible mechanics at least I
can still have my gun out oh
okay
so they brought the monster out that
oh no
so is it pitch black without my light
always [__] black
am I supposed to shoot that
if I shoot that is something going to
hear me shoot that
oh no oh
oh no
what is this
what is this not from the head clerk
important when processing to see
soldiers please check the reverse side
for their of their ID tags for any
messages symbols or Locker Codes these
are to be wiped clean before the tag is
preserved and recorded
ah of course save your progress by
lighting them okay
[Music]
say save
safe room
ah I bet I'm really safe here
I bet I bet I bet what is that
oh a bandage
okay
oh safe good safe ah
good
I maybe I shouldn't have that on me
[Music]
okay
oh I know
oh
okay
to the main map of the bunker that is
not that big okay so I'm in the
administration okay sikram yeah get the
hint out of here can I
I want that hit the hints are there's a
thing about me and Amnesia is I never
turned off the hint system so I guess I
won't do it now
okay so I'm up in administration
generation remember strategic quarters
looks like we got bedrooms there Mission
storage prison Soldier quarter Arsenal
and maintenance okay that seems good
so what about that
so what about all those things
so what about it oh really nothing
nothing at all you just have that
oh yeah update to our medical and
Mortuary Personnel the rat problem has
not gotten any better they're swarming
every dead body they're not even coming
after the wounded but the Vermin have no
interest in flesh after it is burned so
a new policy must be instituted the
bodies of all to see soldiers must be
burned I've spoken to father derai about
this matter he will provide proper
consecration for the deceased remains
will be preserved for families is that
what that burn room was with all the
burn bodies this is not ideal and it
fills my soul with pain but burning the
dead seems to be the only way to stop
the rats from coming so burn them we
must
whatever helps you sleep in that I guess
oh hey well what what is happening uh
okay I didn't mean to do that
oh sick music costs all right
um
for use when wounded on the battlefield
proper use can leave you the most
wounded soldier feeling their best well
better put that in storage and never use
it uh ooh a rag
um
oh oh open for business
hello okay is there anything else over
here like hidden away
oh stupid flashlight there better be
like an upgrade for the flashlight that
I can get down the road or better be
and maybe I don't need it all the time
if there's a generator
um
you all right there buddy okay
oh you can power the generator by
filling with fuel and pulling the lever
I'm sure I can keep on at all times
though
[__] hates the light
you okay
oh man those bandages did not do you any
good oh Morgan that's great
look good
thank you free Lou
uh did you really have to use that
bandage if it wasn't gonna do you any
good luck I don't mean to be picky but
um
it would have been nice to you know
have that
okay I'm assuming by the nice music that
I actually am safe here and it's not
horrible the Beast hunts in the dark the
light is our only chance and the
generator Our Only Hope and must be kept
fueled at all times day and night a
continuous rotation of runs to the main
fuel supply must be maintained watch
each other's backs keep each other safe
do not let the light go out for all our
sakes okay I get it this seems really
important uh yeah okay yeah keep it
fueled all right sure but think about
this what if I don't will I die
generator fuel is extremely flammable ah
whatever shut up
I've dealt with oil and lands all my
life
you tell me these are empty
um okay
how long does one can last I have like
two more
oh man I got a feeling like
[Music]
I just have a feeling like I don't know
enough to use this yet like I get it's
saying oh you really want to use this
you want to keep this on but I have a
feeling like
it's just gonna it's just gonna burn
through it right am I crazy is that a
crazy idea right
I'm not crazy
right
I'm not right I'm not I'm a
oh I'm not crazy
oh I might be crazy oh
[Music]
what's that sound okay didn't I get a
code eight six three four
eight six
three four
[Music]
okay
so I'm
I'm good to go there's a light down
there
is your wits in your brain experiment if
you think something might be possible to
do it probably is
um I think it's possible that I'm gonna
float through the ceiling and go off
home
to party
all right hello
oh my light went out at the same time
I'm just dumb okay
I have not seen another human for hours
now I might be the last but in the hope
there might be another I'll leave this
now so you do not waste any time this is
the only exit the only way out of this
hell is of our own making it was blown
closed it needs to be blown open don't
bother digging impossible blow it up the
dynamite is locked in the Arsenal The
Detonator handle seems to be down in the
Roman tunnels deeper in hell I go now to
try to retrieve them both though I do
not know if you exist I pray for you
please extend me the same courtesy uh
who wrote this
Sergeant boss fall all right Sarge um
you just found a new objective
oh ain't that nice
so you're telling me that I can't dig my
way out oh but it's daylight
I can crawl through there also if
whatever this thing is can drill tunnels
in the rock walls I don't think that uh
a little bit of rubble's gonna be any
kind of a hindrance oh my God
oh well this is on
this is uncomfortable
I just got to get in a good habit of
pulling that cord every once in a while
that looks
this is explosive
is this not gonna work okay
crazy here
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm legitimately out of breath from
doing that good God okay I don't think
I'm crazy right because they said if you
think something's possible it probably
is
I got Dynamite
well I mean I got a barrel of gunpowder
right here unless it's empty or
something I don't know
okay so I hear gunfire out there so it's
still war
M you don't think
I got one bullet
[Music]
did it work
damn it you said if I thought it was
possible it could work here's what you
said all right well it couldn't have
been that easy
all right fine
oh I gotta chill I had like completely
forgotten that it was even a thing
oh you know what it was very dumb of me
or I'm Gonna Save and all will be well I
need to get to the Arsenal and I gotta
get to the exit okay
all right we're all good
I know this isn't the weight of the
Arsenal but it said there was a storage
room over here so
oh I should have had two barrels oh that
would have done it for sure oh but I
don't have another bullet so it's not
even a point oh hi
okay
oh well
okay emergency lockdown I don't know
when they would have made something
sophisticated enough for there to be
lock downable things
oh
hello
that looks kind of important you look
kinda dead
ah it's nowhere
oh
noises dangerous
why am I yelling I should not be yelling
at this juncture
oh I see
nah ah okay so everyone probably has a
code
okay so if I find
hmm
okay
ah well that's handy there's a wheel
there
good
great
all right
I'll cry
oh
ah
so Barden D Barden 1502 got it okay
Barden
Arden
I do not never mind I do not know the
time but dusk dusk has fallen and still
of course
no word
when I asked the sergeant he Shrugged as
if I was asking about when it might next
rain
these fools around me laughing and
drinking arguing
do they know what I've done
do they suspect it
feel they must all be guilty of
something
and yet
they laugh drink argue
God knows what I've done
I wonder if his judgment could be worse
than my own I don't know what you've
done what did what did you do
okay
dip odd
I know what they're doing to me I know
what they're doing I I know it's 1502 I
forget
it's I called it at the beginning of
this it's like they're not going to show
the monster right away they wouldn't do
that because
why would they right they're gonna build
up to it
wait no stucco oh my God
just pull it up man
they're gonna build up to it and they're
gonna you know
they're not gonna
you know it's not gonna be oh I can't
how much do I have what
[Music]
I guess I could come back
and build up to it oh there's so much
gas here oh grenade what is that I gotta
come back for that for sure
anything actually in there is there
anything ever in there
they're real they really threw me off by
putting one in there at first
uh suddenly oh there's nothing oh sorry
Buck oh you don't get any
can I even get out of here oh I see
oh
okay so I gotta drop some stuff off in
the safe room where I'm
you know that actually being blocked
that's probably a good thing
I'm safe
fine okay who this is that pretty fella
put that in there
I just I don't know if like I should
keep nah what is I was Can We sync with
the gender oh so see how much fuel oh
interesting
so it is strategic so you got to be
strategic about your fuel consumption
going out
I bet I'm on the right path I bet I'm a
genius because I'm going out and I'm not
I oh
my gamer instincts are so profound so
luscious so wonderful
although I would have light wouldn't I I
wouldn't have to do this so slowly but
it don't matter uh I've sat in the
darkness in Amnesia before
oh
and I have uh
I've been fine lose a little sanity you
get a little locked on them
that's all you need what is that
gas grenade
I don't see how that could be at all
useful but there it is
also why did I get meat in that other
room
I think I've got everything
I'm gonna go drop off again
and ah of course
whoa my God
sorry
thank you
Okay so
let's just keep those in there what I
can do
probably is I can fill up the generator
but I don't have to turn it on right
oh I'm gonna have a full generator
I wonder if I get a bonus for um
like uh being really super efficient
about it probably not
okay
it's full
so now
if I wanted to I could grab the pocket
watch
sync sync it up
four
I wonder if that's real minutes or like
fake in-game minutes
this is the this
this is the thing it's like you you
all right I'm gonna try
I'm gonna go for this
no all right sucky you got unlimited
resource and you don't want to use it
that's just how it is
oh god oh it's a terribly dumb idea to
go out there without power I bet but
here I go
okay
whatever this infirmary that's where I
was
all right everything's fine
everything's good
I'm just going into the darkness and
that's fine maybe some of these things
don't open up unless they have power but
that's not my problem
I'm here
to say hi to jobert
oh my God
hi Gilbert
oh my God okay Joe Bert's Journal
strange scratching sounds a few moments
ago and now it sounds like someone's
pacing in the hallway probably rainerd
I know what happened drunk on the stash
of wine I know he hides from us best I
confront him now either get him into bed
or sleep it off or convince him to share
a bottle or two with me cold fear runs
through all our veins now Forney air has
terrorized the men for answers they say
they were asleep until Rainer screams I
believe him of course
when so far as to accuse prisoner 73014
escaping a cell and committing the
murder impossible I worry about Fournier
his rage hides fear he takes it out on
the men and I can see no way to stop it
it breeds contempt my mind slips back to
the moment Reynard started screaming how
easily it could have been me how easily
it still could be for the first time I
wish the order to attack would come I'd
rather face a thousand Germans guns than
this nameless dread ah well that was a
quick switch
um oh more Journal uh I didn't even find
this our commanding officer cower is
next to me now flee flee we must flee
and seal the Beast where it belongs he
wants to run and blow up the exit well I
guess he did that Danny my men once were
free this place I'll get the Arsenal
code from him
I will get in my radio back to you ah
Fournier has the Arsenal code
all right communication room in the
Soldier's quarter hi there I'll
broadcast the code to you all right
that's also important
ah
it doesn't look good
oh if I turned on the power dot more
grenade
why is everyone got so much gas I guess
it must be World War One
hey is that a bottle of wine Empty
Bottle great
all right
oh my God
oh
[Music]
is it detonator
all right Engineers have broken through
our storage area into the old Roman
tunnels there's we thought structurally
sound deep and I confessed I was
skeptical of this last point but they do
indeed lead in the direction of the
German line by September we should be in
position to launch a massive push from
inside the tunnels ah see if they were
building this we found urns latinx
Etc we'll do our best to preserve some
material for posterity
right and I'm sure you didn't unleash
some horrible Roman curse from the
Beyond
right
okay gas
let me guess nothing
ah nothing
because why would there
I don't know what after the raid last
evening we have in custody some 20
German soldiers from the fourth Reserve
Corps of the second Army ah 73014 I
would like to hold for his Captree
ripped ripped his Rank and Insignia so
his rank remains unknown since Captree
is refused to say a word
I bet he's alive down here somewhere
that guy seems like a survivor
oh please tell me I can hide in that
oh please tell me the days of hiding in
cupboards is not over X
not a grenade
but I didn't think you would do that but
why would I have thought otherwise
oh no oh no
I don't think the screaming helped but
it felt right to do in the moment
foreign
why am I doing this to myself they told
me the game told me straight up if I
turn on the power I'm good
assuming I'm okay for now
oh
I blew the door right off damn it
okay well I got it open great good
for me was it worth it
I got a rag I can't even
Rex
great
this has gone so good
I was it just a rag okay
God
oh
I haven't even seen anything yet
huh
[Applause]
the meat say you're oh hi oh you are you
not do good
oh
you not do good physically and mentally
good
okay I'm now putting into writing what I
have reported to both of my immediate
superiors last evening 14th of May I was
assigned Aid the rule engineers and
mapping the Roman tunnels as I entered
the deepest area of the tunnels I know
strange glowing liquid seeping from the
walls when I turned around the walls of
the tunnels themselves were suddenly
gone and I was standing in a vast plane
of Darkness
that sounds familiar in the distance
there was a sickly light that seemed to
be calling me forward between it and me
malformed Shadows moved I blinked again
it was gone I was back in the tunnel it
lasted but a split second but I am quite
convinced that what I saw was no
Daydream it was real since that
experience I have felt haunted like a
part of me is still there stuck in the
tunnels I keep seeing shapes moving at
the edges of my vision I'm formally
requesting medical it's paused when I'm
reading this right
okay so strange uh glowing voids in the
I didn't turn on the power because I'm
dumb hi I'm dumb and you're dead
oh good DeLisle five four five oh that's
great
whatever this is I can carry more items
one more best day ever
I can go get that cloth that I blew up
there's nothing else
here I don't know why I'm doing this
oh that's
that's
a gas could a nod
that looks terrible
okay
great infirmary this way wait am I
turned around
also can I jump that
I don't know not worth it
okay oh
it's a circuitious route
it's for going circusly
in circuses
oh
oh I didn't unbarricate it
idiot
okay can I oh God
oh my God
[Music]
I haven't even seen it God
this frictional games does so good at
this feeling of being stalked and it's
nothing is there
nothing is causing a problem I've got so
much [__] I didn't even get that meat
off of that guy and I'm I haven't even
seen it anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
uh I'm Gonna Leave This one here for now
first episode I played for almost an
hour and I haven't even seen it so in
the next one I'm gonna turn on the light
so I can see it thank you I'm looking
forward to playing this one it should be
very very funny let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
uh if you want to go way back in time
you can check out the very first series
I ever did on this channel
which was amnesia the Dark Descent thank
you and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]